[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ابلغت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
الكونجرس بمشروع صفقه بيع اسلحه للعراق
تتضمن طائرات حربيه ومدرعات ومناط مراقبه
بقيمه نحو مليار دولار نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لكي نناقشه في محورين ما دلاله اقدام
واشنطن على ابرام صفقه تسليح لحكومه
المالك في ظل الصراع الذي تخوضه قواته في
الانبار وما هي التاثيرات
المباشره وغير المباشره لهذه الصفقه على
التوازنات الداخليه والاقليميه في هذا
التوقيت بحسب ناطق باسم مجمع الصناعات
الحربيه الروسيه فان دفعه جديده من
المروحيات الحربيه المزوده باجهزه الرؤيه
الليليه وبغيرها من الاجهزه الحديثه تحضر
لارسالها الى العراق بعد تسليم الدفعه
الاولى من هذه المروحيات في اطار صفقه
تشمل في مجملها
43 مروحيه حربيه ياتي هذا بعد يوم واحد
فقط من اعلان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه عن
صفقه اسلحه اخرى اشترتها بغداد
تتضمن فيما تتضمن 24 طائره حامله طائره
حامله للقنابل و 200 مركبه من نوع هامفي
مصفحه هدف بيع العراق طائرات حربيه
ومدرعات واجهزه مراقبه متطوره وغيرها من
وسائل الدعم العسكريه حسب المسؤولين
الامريكيين هو تعزيز القدرات الذاتيه
للقوات العراقيه وامدادها بما يحقق
الاستقرار ويمنع امتداد الفوضى المسلحه
للجوار والصفقه بتفاصيلها المختلفه امام
الكونجرس ومعها بالطبع الظروف التي يعيشها
العراق وفي الذهن الدعوات الامريكيه
المتكرره على لسان مختلف المسؤولين لبذل
كل الجهود الممكنه لمنع انفجار الصراع
المذهبي في العراق وهو الصراع الذي يقول
زعماء العشائر في المحافظات السنيه ان
الحرب التي تشنها قوات الحكومه العراقيه
ضدهم تاتي في القلب منه فبينما يؤكد
المالكي ان حربه في الانبار تستهدف من
يعرفون بعناصر الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق
والشام يؤكد ابناء المحافظات السنيه ان
الحرب هدفها تكريس التهميش الذي تعانيه
المحافظات السنيه بدوافع طائفيه ولصالح
ايران التي يتهمها بعض قيادات السنه في
العراق بالسعي لتحويل محافظاتهم لمعبر امن
يقود الى مسرح حربها الاقليميه الاخرى في
الجوار السوري وفي ظل الضبابيه التي تحيط
بالمشهد السياسي العراقي الراهن فان صفقه
بيع الاسلحه الامريكيه للعراق تثير الكثير
من القلق من حيث تاثيراتها محليا واقليميا
فالمالكي الذي طالما اتهم دول الخليج
وخاصه السعوديه بدعم ما يسميه الارهاب في
بلاده لم يخفي موقفه المعروف بمسانده
ايران في اطار صراعها المكتوم مع السعوديه
وبعض دول الخليج وهو الصراع الذي اتخذ
صبغه مذهبيه تتفاوت تجلياتها حسب مقتضيات
الظروف
السياسيه وهكذا تظل الصفقه مثيره للجدل
ولكثير من الاسئله على صعود متعدده خاصه
وان الاعلان عنها جرى بعد ايام من تعيين
سفير امريكي جديد في العراق يوصف بانه
ضليع في الشؤون العراقيه ويعلم بناء على
ذلك باهميه التوازن في التعاطي مع الملف
الطائفي في
العراق موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
واشنطن صاموئيل برانين كبير الباحثين في
مركز الدراسات الدوليه الاستراتيجيه في
واشنطن والمسؤول السابق وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه من عمان وليد الزبيدي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ومن الكويت مع الدكتور
عبد الله شيجي رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه الكويت ولكن قبل ان نبدا النقاش
مع ضيوفنا نتوقف مع ضيفنا من بغداد عبر
سكايب محمد العجيلي عضو ائتلاف دوله
القانون ربما من حق اي دوله ان تتسلح لكن
العراق الان بحاجه الى تسليح ام الى ابداع
في الحلول
السياسيه نعم شكرا جزيلا استاذ غاده اهلا
وسهلا بكم تحيه لك وجميع ضيوفك
الاكارم يعني بالتاكيد العراق في مواجهه
حرب مفتوحه مع الجماعات المسلحه حرب
ارهابيه
بامتياز العراق يستنفر كل قواه ل ان
يكون بمواجهه هذه الجماعات المتطرفه
الارهابيه انا اعتقد العراق من حقه ان
ينوع مصادر التسليح ولديه اتفاقيه
استراتيجيه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وفي بعض فقرات هذه الاتفاقيه
الامريكيه ان تكون هناك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه احد المصادر التسليح للجيش
العراقي احد مصادر المهمه المهمه في
التسليح بالتالي العراق يبحث عن مصادر
واسلحه نوعيه للقضاء على هذه الجماعات
الارهابيه كون الحرب اليوم مع الارهاب هي
حرب غير تقليديه وحرب شوارع وحرب عصابات
بالتالي نحتاج الى اجهزه نحتاج الى طائرات
عاليه الرصد الى طائرات عاليه
التكنولوجيا لتتبع هذه الجماعات الارهابيه
لكي يتم
يعني ال الحاق الضرر والقضاء على هذه
الجماعات الارهابيه والتي توصف بالغدد
السرطانيه تنتقل منها من هنا وهناك كذلك
المصالح الدوليه والمصالح الاقليميه في
المنطقه تحتم
را السلاح يمكنه ان يع مشكله الارهاب في
العراق يعني بعد هذا التسليح يمكن ان يع
الحكم بالعراق بانه سيقضي على اي نوع من
خلل
امني لا بالتاكيد اليوم الحوار السياسي
بالتاكيد هو مهم والنقاشات السياسيه
بالتاكيد هي المهم و نحن مؤمنين ايمان
راسخ بان الحلول يجب ان تكون غير عسكريه
حلول سياسيه لكن امام عدو لا يقبل الحوار
ولا يقبل النقاش ولا توجد لديه اي خطوط
لمراعاه حقوق الانسان هو يذبح على الهويه
ويقتل على الهويه ويستهدف كل مكونات الشعب
العراقي يستهدف الانسانيه باجمعها بالتالي
لا وجود حلول يعني او حوارات سياسيه مع
هذه الجماعات سوى القوه العسكريه هي من
تفهمها هذه الجماعات المسلحه يعني لو كانت
لهذه جماعات يعني غطاء سياسي من الداخل
العراقي او الخارج العراقي ويقول للحكومه
العراقيه انا اريد ان اتفاوض اريد ان
اتفاهم بالتالي يعني من الممكن لكن هذه
الجماعات لا تقبل الحوار هذه جماعات تريد
الدم هو ان يكون الفيصل في كل شيء
كحكومة حوار مع
هؤلاء لم افهم اي هل بسلاح وحده لا ارجوك
تفهمي ارجوك ان ان تفهمي قضيه محدده ان
الحكومه العراقيه الجديده والنظام
الديمقراطي الجديد في العراق هو نظام مبني
على النقاش وخذ وهات والسياسه فن الممكن
لكن هذه جماعات لا تقبل الحوار زين يعني
اليوم حتى لو كانت فرضا هذه تتحاور مع هذه
الجماعات مع من نتحاور زين طيب الذي يقتل
ابناء الشعب العراقي يعني تكون هناك
حوارات معه او او الذي يستهدف الانسان
يستهدف المسيحيين ويستهدف المسلمين
ويستهدف الاقليات ويستهدف الاكثريه ه هل
معقوله انه اليوم يقتل وانا اتحور
معه لا يرد هذه الاعتداءات الا القوه
العسكريه التي من الممكن ان تحد من هذه
النشط شكرا جزيلا لك على اي حال محمد
العجالي عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون من بغداد
عبر سكايب الى ضيفي من واشنطن صموئيل
سيد برن هل ينفع السلاح وحده في العراق
لحل مشكلته
الامنيه لا لا يمكن للسلاح ان يحل الصراع
في العراق ولو كان ذلك بالامكان لكننا
شهدنا هذا الحال عندما كانت القوات
الامريكيه في العراق لكن هذا استمرار
للمشكله التي رايناها تتكشف منذ العام
2003 و24 وصولا الى الوقت الحاضر اعني
بذلك شرخ كبير قائم في العراق وايضا غياب
للتوافق
السياسي الى جانب ان جزء كبير من الشريحه
السونيه في العراق تعتبر ان الملك رئيس
الوزراء وحكومته هم غير شرعيين ولدينا
ايضا هذا التوتر المذهبي الذي زادته سوء
الاوضاع في سوريا وكذلك ظهور المجموعات
السنيه المتطرفه التي تقاتل في سوريا ولها
علاقات ايضا في منطقه الانبار السلاح
برايي سوف يسمح للحكومه المركزيه في
العراق بان تقوم بعمليات عسكريه اكثر
فاعليه داخل هذا البلد لكن هذا لا يحل
طبعا المشكله بشكل جذري او يقتلعها ما
رايناه على مستوى السياسه الامريكيه هو ان
وزاره الخارجيه قد فشلت فشلت في ممارسه
ضغوط على السياسيين في العراق باتجاه حل
سياسي واليوم الولايات المتحده تتجه نحو
سياسه الدفاع الولايات المتحده طبعا لا
تريد ان ترسل قواتها الى العراق وهو غير
مرحب بها بكل الاحوال كما انها لا تريد ان
تدعم بشكل
مباشر على الاقل بشكل
مفتوح غير سري وليس على مستوى الاستخبارات
الامريكيه بالتالي عمليه بيع الاسلحه هي
طريقه تسمح بتدعيم
الحكومه بد غياب السياسه سيد وليد الزبيدي
اذا عمليه صفقه الاسلحه هذه تسمح بتدعيم
الحكومه
فقط بالتاكيد الامر يحتاج الى دراسه او
رؤيه عقلانيه
للامر القوات الامريكيه خدم فيها خلال تسع
سنوات فتره الاحتلال اكثر من مليوني
امريكي ومئات الطائرات واحدث الاسلحه
والتقنيات الجويه
ولم تتمكن من السيطره او الحد من هجمات
المسلحين الذين قاوموا هذه القوات على
مساحات تصل لاكثر من 250 الف ك متر مربع
وهي المنطقه التي شنت فيها هجمات ضد
القوات
الامريكيه القناعه بان القوه العسكريه
ممكن ان تحل الوضع في العراق هذه يدركها
الامريكيون وغير الامريكيين ايضا وفي
العراق ولكن هناك اصرار امريكي على تن فيذ
المشروع الاساسي وهو ان يتقاتل الشعب
العراقي في ما بينهم ونجد اليوم كما
تفضلتم في بدايه برنامج بان سباق تسليح
للقوات الامنيه العراقيه من موسكو وامريكا
وهذه القوات معروف انها تقتل المئات الان
وتشرد مئات الالاف وتجرح الالاف ايضا
وتدمر الكثير من المنازل في مدن الفلوجه
والسقلات
الذي كان ينتظره العراقيون من الرئيس
اوباما الذي وقف ضد الحرب ان يبدا ببرنامج
حقيقي للضغط على الحكومه العراقيه التي
تخضع للاراده الامريكيه بصوره او باخرى
وبالضغط على ايران التي اصبحت لها قويه مع
الاداره الامريكيه لوضع برنامج سياسي حق
الع ان يكون هناك ضغط سياسي وليس تسليح
لدعم حكومه المالكي دكتور عبد الله
الشايجي مليار دولار قيمه صفقه مع
الامريكيين الله اعلم كم مع الروس ايضا
صفقه الم يكن بالامكان استخدام هذه
الاموال كلها لانماء وتنميه وحوار سياسي
واعمار العراق
وتجفيف منابع الارهاب عوضا عن زياده الطين
بلا بمزيد من التسليح وبساله قد يفهمها
على
بشكل معين اهالي
الانبار يعني العراق في الواقع يمر بماز
كبير جدا لا يوجد رجل دوله لا يوجد اجماع
وطني لا يوجد وحده وطنيه الانتخابات
الاخيره كشفت بشكل واضح ان العراق لا يزال
في نفق طويل الاسلحه من امريكا في يناير
الماضي كان في حتى مو بس يعني العراقيين
بعض العراقيين يتساءلون عن اهداف هذه
الاسلحه المتطوره كان في رفض واضح من
الكونجرس خاصه من لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
ورئيسها
مانديز تسليح العراق بطائرات اباتشي خوفا
من استخدامها ليس ضد كما يعني دائما تقدم
نفسها الان الحكومه العراقيه بانها تقاتل
في جبهه مع مع ضد الارهاب والتكفيريين
وداعش فيما بعد التي تم اختراعها لاحقا
مثل ما يدعي ايضا بشار الاسد ولكن قد
تستخدم ضد خصومه السنه هذا ما قاله رئيس
لجنه شؤون الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي وقرعه اوباما و اتهمت الاداره
الامريكيه الكونغرس ومجلس الشيوخ بانه
يعطل بشكل واضح الادوات التي يمكن من
خلالها ان تساعد المالكي بان يقمع او يقضي
او يتعامل مع الارهابيين للاسف العراق
الان بالنسبه لنا
كجيرته امريكا ليس دقيقا وليس صحيحا تقول
بان هذه الاسلحه الصفقه الاخيره 790 مليون
دولار اقل من مليار دولار هي لاهداف عديده
ل مقاتله القاعده وداعش والارهابيين
بالاضافه لحمايه
المنشات يعني العربات الهامرز والهم فيز ب
101 مليون دولار لحمايه المنشات النفطيه
ولمنع يعني انتقال وتمدد الارهابيين
والارهاب الى دول الجوار العراقي العراق
لا يمكنه ان ينتصر فيما يقوم به الان
كنظام دون ان يقوم بمصالحه سياسيه ودون ان
يدمج المجتمع الذي يقاتله في الانبار
والذي يتم الان استخدام داعش والقاعده
كورقه من اجل تبرير ما يقوم به النظام
العراقي الان الانتخابات كشفت بشكل واضح
ان لا اجماع في العراق ولن يكن هناك في
اجماع العرا نميز هنا بين العراق بين
العراق يعني
كوطن وبين النظام الذي ربما هل يجب ربما
في حديثك ان نميز انت تقول العراق كي يقوم
اي عراق تقصد الناس الوطن العراقي ام
الحكومه الحاليه التي على ما
يبدو ما ما يجري
يناسبها لهذا السبب العراق لا يمكن ان
يقصي
فئه يعني فئه من المجتمع العراق و بالنسيج
العراقي ويكون العراق امنا ومستقرا لان
هذه الفئه طالما هي تشعر بالتهميش فلن
يكون هناك في استقرار ستطالب بحقوقها
وسيتم ايضا يعني الاستفاده من هذا الحرمان
من قبل المزيد من التطرف والمزيد م ما
نراه ثم يتم التعامل معه كارها ويتم دعمه
من الخارج لانه يقاتل الارهابيين فقط نقطه
اخيره بالنسبه لهذه النقطه تقرير الورد
بانك يعني البنك الدولي وليس اي منظمه
اخرى منحازه مع او ضد وهي يعني وهي طبعا
جهه محايده جدا تؤكد بان العراق من اكثر
الدول فسادا اكثر الدول قله في الشفافيه
وان من المفارقات ان النظام المالكي او
حكومه المالكي تسمي نفسها الحزب بالحاكم
دوله القانون وهي حسب تقرير البنك الدولي
الاخير اقل دوله تتمسك وتطبق القانون في
ذيل قائمه الدول وتقول ايضا ان نظام صدام
حسين كان افضل في تطبيق القانون من النظام
المالكي يعني هذا كله منذ 2006 حتى الان
ادانه واضحه للنظام في العراق انه لم ينجح
بان يكون دوله لكل
العراقيين يعني يقوم بخدمه العراقيين كما
كما ينبغي فاصل قصير نناقش بعده التداعيات
الداخليه والاقليميه لصفقه الاسلحه
الامريكيه هذه للعراق نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد سيد
برانان مالكي يقول انه يواجه ارهابا في
الانهار فيما شيوخ العشائر المعروفين هناك
يقولون يجري
تضخيم الموضوع وبان المالك يخوض حربا ضد
السنه تسليحه الان من قبل بلادك الا يعني
انحيازا له ضد السنه في العراق وايضا
رافعه للدور الايراني في
العراق من الواضح وجود شرخ مذهبي في
العراق مازال قائ
بين السنه والشيعه ويبدو ان رئيس الوزراء
المالكي قد فقد دعم السنه وهو خلال
الانتخابات الاخيره لم يحاول ان يكسبهم
الى جانبه من وجهه نظر واشنطن يمكن ان
نقول ان الراي السائد هو ان المجموعه او
الجماعات التي تقاتلها الحكومه العراقيه
ربما هي سنيه ولكنها تستخدم تكتيكات
ارهابيه وذلك ربما في اطار غياب الاستقرار
في المنطقه بشكل اعم لعل رئيس الوزراء
المالكي مخطئ بعدم قيامه بما يكفي فيما
يتعلق بالعمليه السياسيه لكن لا يمكن تجنب
ان يختار الخيار العسكري وواشنطن تدعمه
خلال قيامه بذلك ولكن
دعوني بران عفوا لو
قطعتك اسمح لي انت تقول لابد من الخيار
العسكري في مواجهه هؤلاء امريكا كلها كانت
بعتاد وعدتها وعشرات الالوف من الجنود
كانوا في داخل العراق ولم
يستطيعوا ان يقضوا على المشاكل الامنيه
الان تريد ببضعه اسلحه بقيمه مليار دولار
للمالك وحده ان يقضي عليهم الا ترى ان
شيئا غريبا هنا او او او يعني شيئا فاشلا
قد ينتظركم
راي شخصي هو نعم هذا لن ينجح طبعا لكنه
سوف يحول دون توسع المشكله لكن هل سوف
يموت الناس في حرب اهليه نعم وهل ان
الولايات المتحده قد اختارت طرفا في هذه
الحرب جوابي هو نعم انها تقف الى جانب
المالكي ولا تبذل ما يكفي على المستوى
السياسي لكن يبقى ان القرار قرار هذه
المجموعات السنيه با اختيار العنف والتخلي
عن العمليه السياسيه له تداعياته ايضا ومن
وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده هذا غير مقبول
من غير المقبول ان نشهد هذا المستوى من
العنف الارهابي القائم اليوم في العراق
اذا كل جهد يجب ان يبذل طبعا لاعاده الدفع
باتجاه العمليات السياسيه وعندما يطرح هذا
الموضوع امام مجلس الشيوخ ويكون على
الكونغرس ان يوافق على عمليه باع الاسلحه
سوف يطرح الكونغرس اسئله
لغايه الرئيس اوباما كذلك فيما يتعلق
بكيفيه تحركه على مستوى التسويه السياسيه
ايضا الزبيدي كيف ترى تاثير هذه الصفقه
على العمليات التي تجري في
الانبار المساله اجتماعيه ثم تنتقل الى
جانب عسكري بتقديري عندما يدرك ابناء هذه
المناطق الانبار وصلاح الدين والمناطق
الاخرى المستهدفه من قبل الحكومه بان
موسكو تزود الحكومه باسلحه لتقتلهم ايضا
واشنطن الدوله العظمى تزود المالكي باسلحه
لكي يقتلهم و المالكي يمثل الجناح العسكري
والسياسي لد دوله مجاوره هي ايران انا
اعتقد بان الامر سيزيد من اصرار الكثير من
الناس الانخراط في المجالس العسكريه في
المجاميع المسلحه لان الامر اصبح ليس
مواجهه مع المالكي فقط وحزبه وانما اصبحت
المواجهه يعني عالميه دوليه ومن ثم
اقليميه
هذا الامر ايضا اعتقد
سيستنبط هذا التهديد المباشر وهذا الخطر
الداهم الذي يستهدفهم يستهدف بيوتهم كما
نلاحظ في حال انتهت الفلوجه ودمرت لا سامح
الله ستدمر الرمادي والموصل والمناطق
الاخرى هذه القناعه تترسخ بعد ان يدرك
المجتمع العراقي وقلت الجانب الاجتماعي وم
ثم يتطور الى سياسي ايضا سيجعل السياسيين
ما يسمى بالسياسيين السنه يضمحل دورهم بل
يتراجع وسط بيئتهم
لانهم يعضد الحكومه التي تشتري الاسلحه
وهذا سيفاقم المشكله دكتور
الشايجي كيف ترى تاثير ذلك على الجوار
السوري الجوار العراقي طبعا يعني لا شك ان
ما يجري في العراق مقلق جدا ليس فقط
للعراق كدوله ولكن ايضا لجيران العراق
يعني خاصه في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
وخاصه دولتين السعوديه والكويت المجاورتين
للعراق وما يعني ما يجري في العراق
دلق يعني حتى كل التقارير دكتور كان سؤالي
قصدت فعلا الجوار السوري بالنظر الى
العمليات والى دور تنظيم الدوله في العراق
والشام وكيف ياتي من الحدود العراقيه الى
سوريا وال الحلف ما بين المالكي مع بشار
هل هذا يمكن ان يتاثر يعضد يعضد ان
هناك نعم ان هناك الان يوجد حلف واضح
عراقي سوري يقدم نفسه للغرب بانه يقاتل ال
اجنحه القاعده وعلى فكره قبل يومين اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه بان داعش وجبهه
النصر ودوله العراق والشام هي من ال يعني
صنفتهم منظمات ارهابيه وهذا يعني انها
يعني تدخل ضمن
هذه البوتقه
والصراع الذي يعني يتحد ضد هذه التنظيمات
ولكن يعني بشكل واضح الان انتقل يعني
العراق نجح النظام المالكي بان ينقل يعني
الاحتجاجات السنيه التي دامت لاكثر من سنه
يحولها من مطالب شعبيه يعني مستحقه كثير
منها الى مقاتله القاعده ومقاتله
المتطرفين وينضم بذلك في هذا التحالف الى
الى نظام بشار الاسد وهذا يعني يطي الاد
ويزيد من
المعاناه يعني يجعل الطرف الاخر اكثر
راديكاليه واكثر قابليه لان ينتقم لما
يحجر ذكرت بقيه دول الجوار دكتور وهذا
يقودني الى سؤال سريع عن انه ما خيارات
دول هذا هذه هذا الجوار بالنظر الى انه
يتوقع ان تتصعد العمليات في الانبار مع
هذه الصفقه ما خيارات هذا
الجوار يعني لا يوجد خيارات للاسف يعني
هناك الان تنسيق واضح ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه استمعت الى الموقف السعودي
بزياره الرئيس اوباما الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اي تزويد يمكن المعارضه المعتدله
كما تسمي امريكا المنتق باسلحه نوعيه
لتحقيق نوعا ما اختراق في الجبهه السوريه
ولكن بالنسبه الى الانبار اعتقد الان ان
هناك ستكون معركه يعني مصيريه يجب المالكي
مطالب الان بان يسقط الفلوجه في بعض البقع
وخاصه وسط الفلوجه لا يزال يقاوم امداده
بالاسلحه الامريكيه المتطوره هذه قد يساعد
ولكن لن ينجح الا بدعم العشائر السنيه او
بعضها شيوخ العشائر السنيه ان تلتف معه
ليضع اكثر المكون السني في العراق حتى لا
يطالب بحقائب او بمواقع متقدمه في الحكومه
التي يريد ان يشكلها فهو يقوم بعمليه
عسكريه تحت غطاء محاره الارهاب لضعاف اكثر
المكون الس وصلت الفكره واشكر من واشنطن
سمويل كبير الباحثين في مركز الدراسات
الدوليه وايضا اشكر وليد الزبيدي الكاتب
من عمان واشكر متابعتكم بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر
[موسيقى]
جديد